okay so without further Ado let's embark
on lecture number
18 and let's start where we stop because
we have to cover some substantial amount
of content
today so yeah so we focus on
Transformers and the idea is to use
Transformers for learning Solutions of
PDs right so somewhere up here and our
first attempt that is with the classic
plain vanilla
Transformer if you remember remember
what you can do is your inputs are
functions
here and then you have this positional
encoding you have attention which can be
written as an
operator and then you have this
different kinds of layer
norms and
MLP and so on right so this this
workflow has been very clear and you
also know what is the issue with that so
again uh the fact is that it's quadratic
in the number of token tokens and that's
enough to sort of destroy the
computational complexity so it's
quadratic as you can see here at the
same time it's also important to realize
that there's lots of parallelism the
computation itself doesn't take a long
time but of course it's a pretty intense
computation particularly if you are in
two or 3D because in 3D in particular
this is almost INF feasible so what do
we do so in the last lecture we had
discussed Vision Transformers right and
all that you do in Vision Transformers
is that uh you have patching so this was
the key operator so you cut up the image
into smaller patches so that these are
more manageable and so in know in some
sense you aggregate local information in
order to form this patch embeddings and
then the usual things so you have
attention uh self attention but the self
attention is now on patches rather than
rather than on the pixels themselves
rather than points these are on let's
think of it as cell averages okay and
then you have the usual l you have MLP
and so on right so this the usual thing
and by doing this patching what we do is
that we reduce the number of the
computational complexity the
computational cost significantly because
everything gets divided by the by patch
size essentially right because remember
that so you have a image and then
earlier you you were sort of taking it
at the level of each
pixel or at the level of each point this
made attention expensive and now what
you do is that you divided into patches
so let's say four patches in this
particular case so of course the
computation scales based on the patch
size but as I said means the patch size
can't be too big particularly in the
sort of applications that we have
usually in imaging in Vision the patch
size is 16 x 16 in fact the original
Vision Transformer paper it even called
it as learning images as 16 x 16 words
or something like that I'm paraphrasing
the title but the point is that 16 by 16
is is probably twoo cores for us because
a lot of features are lost just imagine
that if you have some Vortex and you're
averaging it over 16 x 16 nothing is
left so you need to take smaller patch
sizes so the experiments that I'll show
you will be at a patch size of 4x4 the
computation is reduced by a factor of 16
clearly but this is still a lot of
tokens to attend to so towards the end
of last lecture I had given you an idea
that can reduce this even further so the
idea would be to use what are called
windows so so let me explain this
visually so here is an image uh that is
being divided into patches so each of
these are patches okay so even in a
vision Transformer what you do is that
for instance you would compute attention
now attention is roughly speaking the
correlation between patches right so you
take for instance this guy and compute
its uh correlation with respect to
somewhere here and you take let's take
another one this gu here and compute its
correlation with respect to the patch
here so you do these kind of long
distance computations this long path
computations and this is what makes
attention expensive right because this
is intrinsically a quadratic process
because you're taking pairs of points
and you're attending to them in a pair
wise manner so what do we do in this is
that instead of attending to every
single patch or let alone every single
point what we do is that we divide the
domain into another layer of division
these are windows so each of these
blocks here is what is called called a
window so this is a
window and now the attention is uh at
each layer you have fixed division into
Windows a fixed partitioning into
windows and all that you do is that you
only attend to points inside the window
so for instance uh if you want to update
the solution at this point for this
particular layer you take the value from
here you compute the queries and the
keys and then the attenion me attention
weights similarly here here and so on
but if you take a point here no you
don't take that right or if you take a
point here you don't take that into
consideration at all so all the
attension is somehow localized it
happens inside each window rather than
uh inside the whole domain right so this
is sort of the basic idea here and now
you can imagine that uh attention is
only happening at the level of the
windows so it's a window size that is
quadratic right because inside each
window if there are uh windows then
inside each window you have um attention
and that's what gives you the complexity
and if you only have 10 Windows of
course it does not matter how many
patches you have it uh reduces the
computational cost considerably but uh
and how do we write that so in terms of
operators it's uh very straightforward
you have another layer so you divided
things into patches but now you just
bend them together into windows so what
you do is that you divide the domain at
each layer so you can say that L is the
layer
index and then you divide them into
these nonoverlap windows and then how
does the tension look like it's given by
this formula here so the key difference
from the traditional tension is so as
usual you take points but these points
are now just attended these are now no
longer points right these are really
patches so think of these are even
though these are Point values these
Point values are constant across each
patch right so that is theistic these
are like cell averages so you still
compute do this computation right you do
this computation and when you do that
you see that the domain of integration
is now only across the patch on which
this point is sitting so in particular
if you have uh not the patch sorry the
window so if you have a division into
windows and if you are sitting at the
point x you only look at points Y which
are inside here right all the points
here then you take them into
consideration if you move to a different
point here again you get um similarly
all the points inside this window
similarly if you get a point here you
take all the points inside this window
and so on and so forth so of course this
reduces the computational cost
considerably the risk now is that all
this nice things about attention This
Global mixing This Global Information
propagation that goes out of the window
un intended right so it's sort of uh
it's a mixed blessing in some sense you
you reduce computation but at the same
time you potentially take away some of
the expressivity so what do we do
there's a very elegant idea not from me
but from the people who invented this
uh in vision and the idea is simply and
it's a very natural idea all of these
are very very natural things that one
can do which is to shift the windows
across layers so for instance in layer
one or layer l rather you had this kind
of a window description so remember that
these points were attended to this or
let's say that this and this point they
had no connection with each other but
now when you shift the windows and this
is uh you just move them you shift the
windows so that this becomes a window
and because um after all the image is
finite right so that's why just for
visual depiction these things become
windows so you can see now that this
point and this point which are no
connection with each other now these are
perfectly sitting inside the same window
right so of course in the second layer
the points that had very little so in
the first layer it learns this sort of a
localistic local information aggregation
then when you shift the windows it
learns local information aggregation in
different sets of points
then you shift it again it learns it in
different sets of points in different
sets of points and so on So eventually
if you have enough windows and if you
keep on shifting them it's very easy to
imagine that the whole domain is filled
up right so this is a very very simple
theistic and the implementation is also
straightforward you straight you just
move the windows it's it's just a shift
and the idea if you want in terms of
technical terms you reduce what is
called path length across to tokens so
earlier for instance if you fix the
window size or the fix the window
locations the window size is still fixed
then there's no path to do this
computation right so this information
was only happening through some Global
aggregation but now there is a fixed the
path length is only one because in the
next
layer you get this connection so that's
all so it reduces path length in this
sort of iterative manner and uh that's
why the heuristic works right because
then things are attended to and you have
the aggregation of global information
and this is how the whole combination
takes place things are combined in the
following manner okay so this are two
different layers so this is layer l and
this L minus one and this is layer l so
you have a function
input this has already been patched up
so think of it as piece wise constant
functions on each of the patches then
you do a layer Norm this is as before
means nothing nothing fancy happens here
now you applied the windows self
multi-head self attention w MSA and what
is w MSA this is that you attend to
tokens in the same window you attend to
tokens in the same window and so on
right so this operation is well defined
then of course you do a residual
connection you have a residual
connection as before then you do another
layer Norm each time you take an output
you do a layer norm and then it goes to
an MLP and then you have another
residual connection and you get the
answer and then you move the answer here
so this is the uh locally attended
information again you do a layer Norm
each time something comes out you put it
in the layer Norm but now the difference
is that you shift the window so
precisely do this operation right so you
move the window once you move the window
then of course the tokens that were not
attended to before in pairs they get
attended to and then you aggregate
residual connection layer Norm MLP and
keep on doing it right so this is sort
of the basis behind uh spin Transformer
block and you can expect so what are
what are the things why did we do this
because we patching was necessary for
computational efficiency and windowing
was necessary for even further
computational efficiency so that the
sort of the heuristics came together and
then of course the usual processing MLP
is to allow for General nonlinearities
because otherwise the only nonlinearity
was softmax which was throwing things
between 0 and one you need arbitary
nonlinearities in order to get the right
kind of answers this could be really
kellu whatever nonlinearity that you
find layer Norms is always to normalize
so that there are good gradient
propagation properties okay so all this
is well and good and this is the swin
Transformer interpreted as an operator
Transformer here but as we know and we
saw it with CNO also that this was
certainly not enough right because at
the end of the day just having this kind
of single block uh not block because
these are different blocks but we have
to combine them together and this is
what is done okay before that I forgot
that people they keep on so the idea is
to scale up means in the sense that if
you how how if you're more compute how
are you going to scale the model up
right so in particular can we add 20
layers on top of each other yes but then
what could be the potential problem with
that the potential problem could be that
there could be issues with
parallelization there could be issues
with gradient propagation and so on so
there are some small changes that people
have suggested um seems to be very
important changes to scale it up further
so there's one additional layer but
these are very very so I I don't want to
go into details here these are very
let's say straightforward changes just
for computational easier computation so
one of them is that the key was the
scale do product right so what was the
scale do product if you go to
attention it's
here so you take the input you multiply
with the query
you take the input here you multiply
with the key and then you take a DOT
product and you scale it right because
otherwise this will be M members then
you have to somehow get the dimension in
and what people have realized is that
when you have very large scale
operations this is an operation that
doesn't scale as well as it should and
they have replaced it with a what is
called a cosine
similarity so this is the first
Innovation so remember that I want to
replace the dot product with a cosine
similarity which is uh gives you an
automatic scaling and what is a cosine
similarity I think all of you know this
means if you have two vectors A and B A
and B belong to r d so cosine similarity
cos is simply COS of theta cos a b is
the angle between the two vectors right
and what is that a b this is the inner
product mod a mod
b okay so instead of so it's the only
change is that it has some
self-normalization properties that
things are automatically normalized so
you do this computation and this is the
first thing it's and there is some so as
I said it's a scaled cosine so which is
this number here so that's the first
it's not an innovation but uh it is
something to improve the scaling
properties and then there is something
with position coordinates remember that
all the time we have these position
coordinates so instead of giving the
absolute value people give the relative
value in the sense that if you have a
patch so you take the log of the
relative value and this seems to scale
much better so you these are the windows
right and these are the various patches
inside a window so instead of giving X
and Y you give the relative position
which is in no particular order you can
say this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and you
take a log okay you take a log of these
values there's a very simple
mathematical transformation by which you
do it and this seems to be a trick that
enables better gradient propagation
better understanding so this is one
small trick and then of course different
ways of moving lay Norm if you remember
in the original Transformers layer Norm
came after the operation and here they
say and then with the vision
Transformers it came before the
operation as you can see the layer Norm
came before the tension and then for
scaling purposes people realize that it
should be the other way around again so
this is um normalization is something
that you have to determine based on the
problem at hand right sometimes it's
better to do it at the input level
sometimes it's better to do it at the
output level but essentially you change
very little because uh anyway it is done
iterative things are layerwise right so
the inputs to one become the output to
the so outputs of one become the input
to the other and so on so these are some
minor technical details these are not
very important what is important is how
you put them
together and now you can imagine because
you saw CNO
that at least for vision as well as for
PD physics based inputs it makes sense
to have things stacked together in a
hierarchical manner so this is a oh
sorry actually I forgotten
to to record today but there is a
recording available there so they can at
least see the
slides Okay so so this is a
hierarchical uh
multiscale let's say
algorithm this a hierarchical multiscale
algorithm so what does it mean it means
that
uh that you combine different uh things
together in a multiscale manner so just
so the basic structure is always that
you start with the input let me let me
walk you through the entire
uh
throughput you start with the input and
then as always you have the patch
partition and the embeddings right so at
the beginning what you give as input to
this algorithm is going to be the let's
say the patches the value in the patches
the pie cell averages and these things
have to be gotten back right so patch
recovery is the opposite of that so
think of this as some sort of a
downscaling
operation and this as an upscaling
operation because from the patches you
want to go back to the pixels the point
values right and now you give it in this
swim Transformer blocks you recover in
this swim Transformer blocks but you can
see just like we did for CNO that this
is an
encoder and up here is a
decoder so it has this encoder decoder
architecture and what is the point about
the encoder that you start at whatever
scale that you have you keep on reducing
the scale and increasing the number of
channels reducing the scale making it
corsen in space but increasing the
number of channels and so on and the
decoder it's the opposite right you
increase the number increase the
resolution by two each time let's say
and you reduce the number of channels so
that's essentially the same idea here
but taken to Transformers so in
particular this uh patch merging is up
down scaling
right so let us think of it theistically
what does it will do what will it do so
you have a
image you have um
patches so these are patches now right
and let's say that these are patches and
what uh the downscaling operation does
is that it takes some of these patches
together and makes them into bigger
patches so instead of having 16 patches
you have four patches right so that's
the next level of iteration and you keep
on doing it
so this is the patch merging and
similarly there's a patch expansion
which is the opposite of this so just
like a patch merging you have patch
expansion and so on so what you do is
that again you do the same heuristic
which is you reduce the resolution
increase the number of channels this is
what happens with patch merging and
Patch resolution patch expansion is the
opposite that you increase the number of
patches which is means that you upscale
and reduce the number of channels and of
course there are some connections there
is a bottle neck so this is this typical
unet uh type architecture right there's
a bottleneck and in between earlier we
had some residual connections here these
are CNN these are some scalable
cnns this com next are just CNN okay so
there are residual connections and so
this is this allows it for a multiscale
information processing because this is
exactly the same Principle as CNO if I
just had if I cut off here
and just have one layer this is probably
not expressive enough okay so all these
operations are entitled or are
constructed so as to allow for the most
operative word here is
multiscale information
processing so information at different
scales is processed it's uh moved up the
scale moved down the scale and moved
within the scale by using this CNN here
this comex the CNN here it's a fairly
elaborate architecture but it's not
surprising after you have seen CNO right
in CNO we did exactly the same and we
had this kind of elaborate multiscale
architecture that seem to do the job
okay so now this is what is called this
is one particular Transformer it's
called a scalable operator Transformer
you understood its design principles and
now let's see whether it works in
practice or not right so let's see so
here is the first example so you have
the PO equation just the simplest
example that you can think of minus llan
of U equal to F and the solution
operator s takes F to U and F here is
some gaussians okay essentially gaussian
so you can see that this is fub1 FS2 F3
F4 and all that it will do is that it
will diffuse out the gaussians right so
this is uh diffusion equation so you can
see that it diffuses out the gaussians
here diffuses out the gaussians there is
only one gausian here so it's very
easily diffused out and the same here so
it's sort of uh it just diffuses out the
Cs it's difficult to write down an
analytical formula for this right now on
this we are going to run different kinds
of uh algorithms fno o c so what are the
algorithms you will have fno
o CNO and Scot just as an example of a
transformer and what we interested is in
the scaling Behavior right to see
whether it scales better or it scales
worse or what are the what are the what
are the properties and by the way just
uh okay let me explain it
here so as you can see from the figure
we have some error means the absolute
values don't matter what matters is a
relative performance okay so let's look
at fno o first as you can see
sorry as you can see the eror goes down
in a consistent Manner and when you have
8,192 samples it is like 5% somewhere
somewhere out here fno is what it is
it's not very good for these kind of
elliptic problems CNO is very good for
these kind of problems and you see that
behavior here it
goes again I'm allergic it's I don't
have a cold so in case you are afraid
that you'll catch something from me you
can't okay so then uh you can see that
CNO starts very very strongly and it um
it's a for the same number of samples or
let's say whatever you get with the fno
with 8,000 samples you get with CNO with
I don't know 500 samples or something
like that so it's a very efficient
algorithm and what what does this
Transformer do does it have Better
Properties worse
properties what does it have so if you
look at it so there are two versions of
it so fno and CNO are roughly 40 million
parameters
okay 40 million this Scott s is also 40
million I
think and Scott T is 20 million just
just to give uh some some reference and
the first thing that you observe is that
both uh the s and t versions here these
are able to scale they actually do
eventually beat fno in sorry CNO they
clearly beat fno they do eventually beat
uh CNO but you can see that in this
regime when you don't have a lot of data
they are worse off okay so Transformers
they they need a lot of data I would
argue not because I have any Theory but
because of heuristics that even this
amount of data 8,000 samples is not good
enough but anyway these are what the
results are and you see the fact that
actually the smaller model is better
than the larger model okay so the size
is still there's not enough data to feed
the larger model but anyway this is how
how the solution behaves and these are
what the numerical resoles are so at
least you would say that it is in this
particular case it is scaling better and
it is competitive but it's not beating C
by any sort of great margin here right
and this is usually the observation that
uh all this work somehow transform are
not significantly better or worse than
the existing operator learning
algorithms here's another example this
is L mol equations so you have minus
llan of
u+ c^ 2 x u equal to0 with some boundary
conditions I think zero boundary
conditions and this was your so what's
the solution operator s is a mapping
from C to U so the coefficient to the
solution and this is your C1 C2 C3 4 now
it is very difficult to imagine what are
the means how this solution evolves
because this is there's no analytical
formula so these are the Solutions in in
these cases and then you can see yeah so
now let us compare the same algorithms
and see where we
are and very very similar the errors are
larger here because this is a harder
problem f o clearly doesn't do well um
it's it's not very good for these kind
of problems and you can see that among
the three algorithms so so here somehow
the larger model has slightly better
capacity they they're sort of comparable
to each other it's not a huge difference
you know they are let's say with 496
samples let's put the number here you
can see one has like 2% error something
has 2.8% error CNO has 3.2% error and
again neither in terms of computation
nor in terms of storage these are the
same kind of models right 20 million 40
million and so on so these models are
comparable to each other and even though
Transformers have many many more
parameters uh or they don't have many
many more parameters here but the
compute is the inference time the
training time is not different because
they are highly parallelized so the
point is okay it's sort of competitive
comparable but by no means is it orders
a magnitude better or something like
that
right the next example I want to show is
uh a Time dependent problem I think it's
a wave equation so maybe I have a movie
here okay so as you can see so what is
it so this is the wave equation so you
have um let me can I I can't write it
down here so okay let me show you so
this is uh down are the coefficients
okay down are the coefficients you can
think of it as um what happens under the
ground up H is the solution so these are
the initial data so these are like
little earthquakes that are taking place
under the ground and then the waves are
moving okay so as you can see it's sort
of for some reason I'm not able to slow
down the movie but you can see that
these things attract not attract but
interact defract and so on and they move
around okay again the solution is not
something that you can write down you
need either a numerical method or you do
what we have been doing right so this
was the wave
equation so okay so this was elol so
this is wave uh so so what is the
equation here utt minus c^ 2 of XL of U
= 0 and U at x0 is some U and U at x0 is
equal to some U1 so this is wave
equation so you have the displacement as
well as the velocity and the solution
operator takes both the coefficient the
C and the initial conditions U U1 and it
Maps them into the final solution okay U
at dot so now we are again comparing
these three methods Scot now this is a
40 all of them are approximately 40
million
parameters uh and uh the number of this
is the number of trajectories remember
now this is a Time dependent problem
right number of trajectories and I think
uh for each trajectory we have I'm not
about 10 saves okay you could see from
the image that there were 10 saves and
remember that there is this quadratic uh
because we do this all to all training
so per trajectory you have something
like 100 or 200 data points so there's a
lot of data okay compared to the
elliptic problem the steady state
problem there's a lot of data and again
uh same story of course uh if the the
the numbers here are the errors are
larger but as you can see that uh again
compared to fno both CNO and Scot do
better and Scot scales slightly better
in this particular case so for instance
with 512 trajectories you can see that
it has a bit better error than CN okay
so again similar to what we had seen
before nothing dramatic here no you
don't lose anything because it's not
like you have more computation you don't
gain anything here the data is the
constraint in some sense means we even
if we increase the model size by an
order of magnitude you don't have simply
enough data to for the model to digest
so this was with the wave equation the
next one is a I think it was Alan Khan
um how do I do this done
alen Khan so Alan Khan is a reaction
diffusion equation right so you have
initial data to
Solutions and here it is very
straightforward in some sense the
Dynamics it depends on whether there is
some material or not whether it's above
the threshold if it's above the
threshold it um changes the phase if not
it mixes out so it's very the physics is
not very difficult to explain but of
course it's difficult to write down the
solution right so this was alen conon
and uh so the equation was what is the
equation
now I always make a mistake with the
nonlinearity but some u 1 - U or 1 - u^
2 one of these two but I think it was
cubic huh squar right it's cubic okay
because 1 minus U is kppp okay now again
the same same picture there is not a
huge difference uh fno is better
performing in this particular case the
error goes down again you really don't
see a huge difference between C and
uh and um Scott they are all comparable
to each other and okay there's a slight
difference but it's nothing much to
write about right it's sort of as I said
they they're really comparable and the
last example uh which is uh from Navia
Stokes it's not the sheer lay but it's
also I put a tracer so these are the
velocities initial velocities and what
happens afterwards so there is of course
some nav Stokes type Dynamics you can
see that in the Tracer there is much
more variation as expected right anyway
some initial data and some final
Solutions Tracer is given by another
equation just uh velocity moving it
around
sorry okay so this is the last example
this is still Navia Stokes I'm not going
to write down the equations again it's
the same story over and over again that
uh yes um there is a perhaps a slight
gain so if you take 1024 trajectories or
let's say 512 trajectories one has let's
say I don't know four or 5% error the
other has 6% error something like this
you know so they they're they're in the
ballpark they're better than fno which
is more like 12% error but okay nothing
to jump in but out right so the point is
just having Transformers doesn't mean
that our problems are dramatically
solved okay we put in a lot of effort
but they are at best comparable to C and
that there is there are there are some
reasons Based on data intensity and so
on about that okay so now what is so we
still have this issue of sample
efficiency right for instance uh we
still need how many samples to we have
still not reached 1% but let's say 2% I
still need 248 samples which is which is
quite expensive and it's sort of I've
not solved that problem in any
particular manner but now in the last uh
I don't know 10 minutes there's not a
lot of time I can give you some rough
ideas of what we could do right so one
thing that we could do is what we did in
the first part of the course so this
sort of connects us with the first part
of the course which is that we can add
physics what do I mean by that what I
mean by that is so far what we did is
that we did not bother about the physics
at all we had lots of data and we use
the data to train the neural operator so
can we add physics to it so how would
that look like let's say whether it's
fno CNO Scot the architecture does not
really matter
let's say that uh my solution op is this
s this is your solution
operator and the pde is like L of U
equal to F right so what I could do is
that I could during the training process
I have the loss due to the data so s of
uar minus s star of uar so this is my
usual sort of supervised loss but with
some Norm but to it I add a physics
inform loss which will be l
this is the differential operator s star
of UB this is the solution of the PD
minus ubar it should have been
ubar yeah L of U equal to U right so
minus U Bar something like this so I
have a physics in form loss right so in
what's the difference with pins in pins
we did this with just space and time as
the inputs but now the whole initial
condition itself is the input and these
have a name these are called physics
informed neural
operators so physics inform neural
operators I really don't have the time
to cover them and there is a good reason
why I don't have the time to cover them
because they don't yes
James they don't really work for the
same reasons that uh pins don't really
work right that you still have to train
them that that problem is not uh not
solved so you need similar kind of uh
problems there are some conditioning
issues just because you're using uh
different architecture doesn't mean
anything because you're still having to
differentiate and so there are some
advantages to this but uh by no means
are the training problems solved you had
a
suggestion struggling could you also
include conser properties in physics
yeah you could uh conserve but I don't
think that is going to dramatically
improve because the with CNO and Scott
they were sort of they needed data but
they were doing the job in sort of it
depends on in those problems perhaps 5%
error is good enough you know you don't
need 1% error me those are also very
hard problems right so it's uh Ben might
tell you a little bit more about how
pins can be used for that problem pins
are no are comparable in terms of the
efficiency in this in this case Okay so
this is still very much an open area of
research because we still
don't uh the same problems that I told
you are inherited by these models right
that you still have to understand how to
train them that is by no means solved so
what we could do is and this is what is
at the moment the most promising
Direction I at some point I promis that
I will cover it but I'm really out of
time because Ben takes over from
Wednesday but I'll give you a little
little Glimpse is that we can do what
are called Foundation
models so maybe if there is time at the
end of the lectures uh end of the
lessons I'll come back and talk about it
but what are Foundation models
Foundation models are essentially models
which are trained on very large amounts
of data right so like just imagine chat
GPT or whatever Gemini Claude whatever
llama whatever large language model this
is essentially trained on what are
called internet scale databases right so
in particular what you do is that like
chat GPT for instance it is not just
English French German Hindi whatever
languages they Club it together and also
very diverse kinds of all kinds of text
right they're not just about medical
reports scientific papers and so on so
large quantities of diverse data so what
and same with the vision models means
you look at uh stationary images you
look at color images you look at stock
images objects semantic information
whatever so you have large so the the
key ter term here is large quantities
large diverse data
sets and these are coupled with scaled
up
models so whatever model architecture
that you have whether it is uh units or
whether it is Transformers you have to
in order to digest this huge amounts of
data you also need very very big models
that's why you have trillion plus number
of parameters and the data set size is
the whole of internet right so this is
the sort of data scill that you are
talking about so for our purposes that
would mean diverse data sets would be
different kinds of pdes and for each PD
different types of solution operators
different types of data distributions
and so on and uh this is slowly the
research is happening also in my lab
there is some research there'll be a
paper coming out probably before the end
of the course and the whole point is
that if you couple this so large diverse
data sets is would be different types of
PD
different types of
PD and different data distributions
right so the measure the underlying
measure also has to be different you put
all of them together and then you scale
up the models and this for instance we
have experimented here with CNO and with
Scot Transformers and this combination
at least the initial results are very
very promising so the idea is that you
train on this very large scale data sets
and then this is at the level of what is
called pre-training pre-training is um
what you do in the beginning but when
you deploy the model you have to do
something called fine
tuning so fine tuning is on your
particular distribution right so for
instance just imagine Navia Stokes so
Navia Stokes we have already seen sheer
layer we have seen some other examples
you could you could think of different
kinds of initial conditions you train
your model on all these different kind
kinds of initial conditions you are you
store the model and now you are putting
it for this example that I showed you
with pie byce constant data then you
take a few samples and you download it
you sort of fine tune in the sense that
you just change a few parameters you you
start the training not from random but
you started from the existing model
right and this works okay so fine tuning
is with few
samples few
samples this requires a lecture of its
own but anyway in 5 minutes this is what
I can do and the initial results are
that it works and I'll show you one
example so remember it's the same
example that I showed you before the
Navia Stokes example all that I have
done is I have used some Foundation
models in addition so remember that we
were uh somewhere here before right so
in order to get uh let's say that we are
somewhere here with 248 samples you are
getting an error of approximately I
don't know 3% or something like that now
with the fine tune model you can get the
same error with eight
samples okay so or if you want the F and
o means this was going only here and
this is with 2048 samples you get it
more or less with one sample you know
that's not because this is trained on
one sample because it has been trained
this model that I'm showing you it's the
one that works here also the CNO one
works not not as well but the
Transformer one really works this is 200
million per model so it's a much bigger
model however it has been trained on
various kinds of equations Navia Stokes
compressible Oiler different kinds of
data sets so it has learned something
about time dependent pdes or fluids and
so on and then it uses that information
in addition with a few samples eight or
16 samples it can very quickly you know
to get 1% error you you just need around
128 samples so it sort of learns very
quickly how to use this information and
deploy it so that is the strength of
what has been done with text and
language and slowly we are making that
move in this domain also but I have run
out of time
yes uh the is even worse on the initial
large model because the data amount of
data that is there so the initial large
model this is a good question but this
will be even worse because um okay so
the initial 40 million parameter model
is somewhere here I I have hav't tested
it but I guarantee you that it will be
probably somewhere here because the
initial large model simply doesn't have
enough data to deal with the problem
that you have it's a lot of data but
still not enough data for a for a large
model okay so the initial but there a
good question means what will the
initial is not because of the model size
because otherwise you wouldn't have a
picture like this right where okay this
one was not remember this one so this is
a classic example where a smaller model
as you can see provided better answers
than a larger model simply because the
amount of data was not there so this was
20 million and this was 40 million in
this particular case and I expect
something similar but we I I don't have
the results but I'm pretty sure of uh
what I just said okay so it is uh
because there is a very delicate balance
between data and compute or not compute
but model sici because compute is the
sort of product of these two things and
this is still in this field people are
also for llms it's uh more or less in
its infancy people have not yet
understood but here means it's really in
its infancy what are the relationship
how much of data do you need what is
large data all these questions are a
little bit up in the air right so but
this is really contemporary research
means papers are not yet out and this is
where things stand so I think with that
I finish my lectures I think Ben starts
uh he starts with he changes gear he
takes he I think he talks about Hybrid
models next I don't remember if uh and
then if there is time I can come and
finish Foundation models but uh only if
there is time otherwise I see you
towards the end of uh end of the
lectures so thank you very much and uh
ciao